FOR GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY I AM THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY JOINING ME ON
THE DIESS IS VICE CHAIR CHOI
WELCOME I WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
ITEMS ON CONSENT AND- WHEN BILL
WILL BE HEARING TODAY WILL START
AS A SUB UNTIL IT IS FOR A-
TODAY WE HAVE ONE TEMPERATURE
PART- COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP THAT
IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER IS
FILLING A VACANT POSITION WE ARE
ALSO JOINED BY TWENTY I'M IS OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT OF THE ASSEMBLY
JOBS CAN BE. AND WE DO ALSO HAVE
THE CONSULTANT OF THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS POLICY UNIT. OVERVIEW
TODAY'S SCHEDULE WE HAVE THREE
BILLS INCLUDING AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY NINE AB TWO TWO SIX AB.
TWO TWO ZERO ZERO. THERE ARE TWO
BILLS ON CONSENT ITEM ONE AND
ITEM TWO THAT IS AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY NINE IN AB TWO TWO TWO
SIX. I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL LIST OF SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. MEMBERS ARE YOU DO
HAVE THAT LIST OF SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITH YOU AT YOUR DESK
BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR BILL
PRESENTATION I NEED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW. OF HOW THE PUBLIC
WILL BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING. DUE TO. THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHERE
PARTICIPATING PHYSICALLY
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE DO STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE MASS TO BE WERE IN
PHYSICAL DISS ST TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WE HAVE A FEW
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. THAT IS ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN OF THIRTY. IS ANYONE
WISHING TO USE THIS OPTION. I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE TIME WHEN YOU
ARE READY TO TESTIFY. FOR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IF ANYONE IS
USING THIS OPTION I YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WILL HAVE THE BILL
WITNESSES YOU MAY. BE MAKING USE
OF ITS OPTION AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
NUMBER. SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU THE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. YOU MAY BE ASKED
BY THE MODERATOR TO IDENTIFY
WHETHER YOU WILL BE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
STILL WAITING ON AN AUTHOR. BUT
ONE MOMENT. SO LET'S ESTABLISH
QUORUM. IF I COULD HAVE- THE
ROBOCALL PLEASE. SURE CERVANTES
HERE CARES ABOUT THE HEARING
VICE CHAIR CHOI HERE FIVE YOUR
CHOICE HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER HILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROSTER NUMBER RAMOS. HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MET. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. SO MEMBERS NOW THAT WE
HAVE A QUORUM COULD BEGIN THE
REGULAR ITEMS OF BUSINESS DO I
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
FILE IN THE SECOND. WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR A DOCTOR CHOI IN THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
FRG CONSULTING CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
CONSECUTIVAS ITEM IS EIGHTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE. ANIMOTION
IS DUE PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
RECOMMEND CONSENT THE SECOND
ITEM IS ITEM TWO AB TWO TWO TWO
SIX THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PARKS AND
ENTERTAINMENT RECOMMEND CONSENT
. SHARE I HEAR CERVANTES FIVE
NINE FIVE CHURCH HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER SEVEN MEMBER WHO
HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
. SEVEN MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS SENATE
MEMBER RAMOS HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH. SO WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
CALL OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON. IN OUR LAST ITEM OF BUSINESS
WE ARE STILL WAITING ON THE
AUTHOR.
WELCOME THANK YOU CAN. WE CAN
SPEAK AS A TO DO ARE HERE ON
ITEM THREE AB TWO TWO ZERO ZERO
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
RELATING TO THE ONLINE JOBS AND
ECONOMIC SUPPORT RESOURCE GRANT
PROGRAM BEFORE THE AUTHOR BEGINS
THE BILL PRESENTATION LET ME GET
EVERYONE KNOWS PHONE LINES ARE
NOW OPEN FOR WITNESS WITNESSES
TO GET IN THE QUEUE AND AGAIN
THAT NUMBER IS TELEVISED BEFORE
YOU DOCTOR RAMBLE I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU WILL BE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED
IN THE COMMENTS SEVEN OF THE
BILL ANALYSIS. YOUR THANK YOU.
OR OR- HELLO NEWS. NBC AB.
DEMOLITION ON JOB. WHEN WE- RUN
THE ONLINE. WE DO WE HAVE
RALLIED AROUND. EVEN MORE.
GENERAL SERVICES SOCIAL SERVICES
- HERE THREE ALMOST FOR
INDIGENOUS CREATED CLARK HERE TO
MISTER. AS THE RIGHT. THE STATE
. WANTS.
YELLOWCARD FROM THE LATINO
POLICY AND POLITICS INITIATIVE
AT UCLA'S LUSKIN SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND KRISTIN
BOLDON THE CHIEF OF STAFF FOR
BITWISE INDUSTRIES. SO WE COULD
GO AHEAD AND HAVE MISS CARMONA
WITH THE LATINO POLICY AND
POLITICS INITIATIVE AT THE SILLY
LUSKIN SCHOOL OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS.
BEGAN. MISTER MODERATOR. WE CAN
GO AHEAD AND GO ON TO THE NEXT
WITNESS MISS BELDEN WITH THE
BITWISE INDUSTRIES. THE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KRISTEN
DALTON AND I'M THE CHIEF OF
STAFF OF IT WAS INDUSTRIES. AND
IT WAS IS PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY LEFT FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN THAT WHITES
HAVE BEEN TRAINING UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE FROM OVERLOOKED CITIES
FOR JOBS AND THE DIGITAL
ECONOMY. OUR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
OF TRAINED OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
STUDENT WORKERS. WITH 80% OF JOB
SEEKERS FINDING EMPLOYMENT AND
TECH JOBS FOLLOWING OUR PROGRAM.-ALL RESULTING IN TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AGGREGATE WGES. MOSTLY FOR
WOMEN AND MINORITIES. MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE GONE FOR
MAKING UNDER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
TO WELL OVER SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR. FURTHERMORE
THE TECHNOLOGY CONSULTING SIDE
OF OUR BUSINESS HAS HIRED MANY
OF THESE STUDENTS TO HELP CITIES
BUILD. AND STRENGTHEN THEIR
DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE. PROVING
IT IS POSSIBLE TO BUILD STELLAR
TECHNOLOGY WITH DIVERSE.
NONTRADITIONAL TALENT. ACCORDING
TO A REPORT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY LOST ONE
POINT SIX MILLION JOBS. BETWEEN
FEBRUARY AND SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY. THE HIRING HAS SINCE
REBOUNDED THE NATURE OF WORK AND
THE SKILLS EMPLOYERS SEEK HAVE
CHANGED PERMANENTLY. IN ADDITION
THE HARDEST HIT WORKERS
INCLUDING LATINOS WOMEN AND
WORKERS UNDER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD. CONTINUE TO FACE STEEP
BARRIERS TO CONNECTING WITH
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO. THESE
COMMUNITIES NEED A HOLISTIC TOOL
TO CONNECT THEM WITH TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT LEAD DIRECTLY
TO JOBS EMPLOYERS HIRING
LOCALLY. AND SUPPORT SERVICES
SUCH AS CHILD CARE. AB TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED WOULD ESTABLISH A
GRANT PROGRAM TO ADDRESS THESE
NEEDS FUNDING ACCESSIBLE EASY TO
NAVIGATE ONLINE TOOLS AND
PLATFORMS. CAPABLE OF PROVIDING
THESE SERVICES AS WELL AS
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT ENSURE
PEOPLE WITH LOWER DIGITAL
LITERACY CN CAN AND DO USE
THESE PLATFORMS. BY PROVIDING
FUNDING TO BOTH DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INNOVATIVE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AB TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED AIMS TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ROOT CAUSES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT GAPS EXACERBATED BY
THE PANDEMIC. AND BOOST THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
REVOLUTIONIZES ONLINE JOB MARKET
PLACES TO PROPEL A JUST RECOVERY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND GO BACK TO. MISTER MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE I MISS CAR MAN ON THE
LINE WITH US.
MISTER MOORE AND ARE YOU WITH US
. YES IT BEGAN. CRITICS THANK
YOU EVEN WHEN MY NAME IS
GABRIELA AND MONICA I
CONSERVATIVE POLICY ANALYST AT
THE UCLA LATINO POLICY AND
POLITICS INITIATIVE WHICH IS A
MULTI ISSUE POLICY THINK TANK
FOCUSED ON BUILDING DEMOCRATIC
INCLUSION AND ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY CORONATION ST
BERKELEY GROWING LATINO
COMMUNITY- THANK YOU ALL FOR
ACCORDINGLY THE PRIVILEGE OF
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF.
220-080-2200 BEING THAT IT'S A
LOT STABLE. TO MONTH- IF YOU'LL
STAY THAT I COULD TO THEM FOR
THE OF THE WITHIN THE CURRENT
STATE OF NOT ENOUGH IN THE U. S.
WORK FOR. AND THE NEED FOR THREE
WIDE TO UNLEASH THE POTENTIAL.
REALLY IT'S ALL AN ADDRESS THE
VERY OF OUR MARCH. THAT WE CAN
AND THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
THE SAMELEVEL OF ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. EARLY IN THE SECOND
AND I CALIFORNIA LOST THREE
MILLION JOBS. LATINO AND BLACK
RESIDENTS AT 22% IN 26% JOB WALK
RATES RESPECTIVELY ALEXINA
NATIONALLY. REALLY TOOK THE
BRUNT OF IT. FOR THE DEMOCRATS
OF NOT BEING UP IN THE S. LABOR.
FOR TO GROW BY FIVE POINT EIGHT
ACT. BUT TODAY WE HAVE SEPARATE
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF JOB
LOSSES. UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND
DEPARTURES FROM THE WORK FORCE
ALL TOGETHER. UNDERSTANDING THE
BARRIERS TO PUT NOTHING NOTHING
FINANCIAL PRECARITY I MADE THEM
VULNERABLE TO THE ECONOMIC
SHUTDOWN IT'S CRUCIAL TO
ADDRESSING THE OBSTACLE
PREVENTING MILLIONS FROM
REALIZING AND SATISFYING THEIR
ECONOMIC NEEDS. ALTERNATELY IT'S
NOT JUST A MATTER OF IMPROVING
WAGES. BUT IMPROVING ACCESS. TO
WRITING SECTORS OF OUR ECONOMY.
AND DEMOCRATS ENOUGH MAKES
DOLLAR AN HOUR TWO FIVE LESS
THAN THE US AVERAGE WORKER THIS
IS MAINLY DUE TO THE FACT THAT
THE F. HIGH PERFECT REPEATED AND
LOW PAYING SECTORS LIKELY SURE
HOSPITALITY. INDUSTRY THAT WALK
ALMOST HALF OF ITS JOB IN THE
FIRST THREE MONTHS AT THAT. OUR
AND I WANT TO AND- WITH. THIS IS
OUR CLEAR THE CALL MY MOMENT
FOUR IN TEN LATINO INTO. ALONE
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION WORKERS
ARE EMPLOYED IN OVER REPRESENTED
IN LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY BUT
ALSO CONSTRUCTION AGRICULTURE
WHOLESALE AND RETAIL TRADE
INDUSTRIES. WHICH ARE THE LOWEST
RATE THE DIGITIZATION I WILL
LIKELY SUPPORT SIMILAR JOB
LOSSES. BUT THIS TIME DUE TO
AUTOMATION TECHNOLOGY IN THE
COMING DECADE. ECONOMIC
PRESSURES OF JOB INSECURITY HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES ALSO ON
BOB DROP BOB THIS IS JOB
CREATION. AT SIX POINT 5% MEDINA
FOR SELF EMPLOYED AT AT LESS
THAN HALF OF THE RATE OF THEIR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS AND THE GAP
CONTINUES TO GROW. UP YEAH NOW
OFFICIAL EFFECT IN 202140% OF
SELF EMPLOYED BUT- STILL LIVED
IN OR SUPPORTED A HOUSEHOLD.
THAT HAS LOST INCOME DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC WHICH HAD DOWNSTREAM
AFFECTING THEIR ABILITY TO RUN
THEIR OWN BUSINESSES AND FOSTER
MUCH NEEDED JOB CREATION BUT
ALSO MEET THE MOST BASIC
HOUSEHOLD EXPENSES. THIS IS WHY
AB TWENTY TWO HUNDRED PAIRED
WITH CRUCIAL INVESTMENTS IN OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN HELPING TO
STRENGTHEN OUR WORKFORCE. IN
FUNDING THE CREATION OF ALL MY
RESOURCES. IF THAT WOULD NOT
ONLY HELP FACILITATE JOB
PROSPECTS FOR THOSE UNEMPLOYED
BUT ALSO PROVIDE INVALUABLE
TRAINING TO UPSKILL AND RESKILL.
ALL WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO A
MORE RESILIENT AND BETTER PAID
EMPLOYMENT UP BETTER PLEASE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
HOW CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVELY.
RIGHT THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SOME LET ME ASK
THERE'S ANY WAY IN THE HERE ROOM
WISHES SPEAK OF THE BILL. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MARKER. SEEN AND S.
R. IS OUR IN THE TOUCH STATION.
MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE
ON THE CONFERENCE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. IMAGINE GERMAN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE AT THIS TIME. SURE NO ONE
HAS SHOWED UP AT THE START. LET
US DOWN HERE FROM THE OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE ROOM. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. THE
THEY DO HAVE JERRY GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS THERE WARRANTY
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA'S FORTY.
ALL BUT WE ARE NOT OFFICIAL IN
OPPOSITION THAT HAVE SEVERE
CONCERN AROUND INCLUSION OF THIS
PROGRAM DATA BREAKING BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE SO LIKE
THANK YOU AS WELL AS A MAIN
OFFICE BUILDINGS IN THE MEDIUM
AND WE HAVE NO FORMAL AMERICAN
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THAT CHANGE
TO THE BILLING OR PLEASED TO SEE
THIS. THANK YOU. THREE ONE ELSE
IN THE HERE ROOM WHO WITH TO
SPEAK UP. IS THERE ANYWAY IN THE
REMOTE TESTER STATION. MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE KNOWN AND YOU AT THIS
TIME. LET ME TURN TO- THE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE DICE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
ASK QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. WE
HAVE A MOTION IS- SECOND WE HAVE
A SECOND MOTION BY. SARAMA
SUSPECTED BY DOCTOR CHOI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS HI
GOOD MORNING I'M STILL THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF VERY WELL
ESTABLISHED JOB SEARCH SITES.
ONLINE TODAY I'M I'M NOT
COMPLETELY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT. YOU
VIEW TO BE SORT OF THE UNMET
NEED IN THE CURRENT ECOSYSTEM AS
IT WERE- AND THEN HOW
SPECIFICALLY YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO FILL THAT- AND PARTICULARLY
HOW YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO I IN A
WORLD WHERE YOU KNOW THERE'S
PLENTY OF NAME BRAND JOB SEARCH
SITES HOW WOULD FOLKS THAT ARE.
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM THAT.
HOW WOULD YOU BUBBLE TO THE TOP
IN TERMS OF THEIR JOB SEARCH SO
IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO IT TO SOME
OF THAT THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
ME- I WILL SPEAK TO THE GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WE ARE ESTABLISHING
WITH THE BILL I WILL DIRECT THE
WORK FORCE GAPS QUESTION TO
GABRIELA CARMONA IF I CAN AND I
WILL HAVE. KRISTIN SPEAK ABOUT
ONWARD CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE
WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
SUCCESSFULLY. THE POINT HERE IS
REALLY TO CREATE A GRANT PROGRAM
FOR THE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
TO HELP MANY OF THESE UNDER
RESOURCED. COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
HISTORICAL GAPS. WILL TO HAVE
THE- TRAINING AND SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT ARE NECESSARY WE
HAVE TO ACTUALLY. BRIDGE THOSE
GAPS IN THE DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH THIS
GRANT PROGRAM- SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE DID IN ONWARD CALIFORNIA WILL
HELP US TO DO THAT. BUT I'D LIKE
TO DIRECT THE WORKFORCE GAPS
QUESTION TO MISS CARMONA IF I
CAN. YES PERFECT DOT COM SO I
THINK JUST TO REITERATE SOMEONE
OF BLACK WITH PART OF MY
TESTIMONY BUT I THINK THERE JUST
NEEDS TO BE A MUCH MORE DILIGENT
AND FOCUSED. ON STRENGTHENING
TRAINING AND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
UPSKILLING AND RESKILLING LET
THE NOTHING SPECIFICALLY LIKE
THE NOTHING OUR LABOR MARKET WE
KNOW THAT THEY JUST HAPPEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY BARRED FROM
ACCESSING HIGHER WAGE
EMPLOYMENT- AND ESPECIALLY WAY
IMMINENT THREAT REALLY I DO
AUTOMATION OF LOW WAGE WORK SO I
THINK REALLY JUST TAX CAN'T
CLOSE OUT AND JUST REALLY- YOU
THINK. OF THAT EITHER. WHAT WE
SHOW THEM THAT. OVER IN THE- ON
INDUSTRY THAT WE KNOW ARE HIGH.
CORRECT THE MISSION I THE
AFRICAN. WE AND HOW. WHOLESALE
AND RETAIL TRADE ON THOSE FOR
INDUSTRIES EMPLOY ABOUT TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOLKS I'M
NOT 40% OF WHICH ARE LIKE YOU
KNOW WORKERS. OR 40% OF LATINO
WORKERS WORK WITHIN YOU TO TREAT
INDUSTRY SO THERE IS A REAL
IMMINENT NEED ON TEN MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DELIVERING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVES. AS WELL
AS- FACILITATING A PATHWAY TO
GET PEOPLE OUT OF THESE LOW WAGE
SECTORS- ARE. ME SHE'S THAT
INTO- HIGHER INCOME DROPPED. I
WILL NOW HAVE IT'S OKAY MADAM.
MISSPELLED SPEAK TO ON WORD
CALIFORNIA AS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
THIS HAS WORKED ALREADY. THANK
YOU DR A BILL THAT. I CAN JUST
QUICKLY SAY THAT WITH THE LAUNCH
OF ON GRID CALIFORNIA AT THE
BEGINNING AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC AT WHAT SET THE
TOOL APART. IS THAT IT WAS NOT
JUST ONE JOB PLATFORM WHICH IS
DEEPLY IMPORTANT BUT- NUMBER ONE
IS INTEGRATED WITH SO MANY OF
THE STATE RESOURCES ALREADY
AVAILABLE AND SO EVERYTHING IS
HOUSED UNDER ONE UNIT SO NOT
JUST. JOB OPPORTUNITIES BUT
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES AND
ESSENTIAL LIVE SERVICES THINGS
LIKE CRITICAL AS A CHILD CARE
AND YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S FOOD
AND SECURITY ISSUES. SO THEY ARE
NOT NEEDING TO GO TO ONE
PLATFORM THEY'RE NOT A MEETING
TO GO TO MULTIPLE PLATFORMS.
WELL TO PULL ME IN. AND I THINK
ON THE OUTREACH COMPONENT THAT'S
ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE
THAT WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
ACTUALLY. DOUBLE DOWN ON IN THE
WAY WE WOULD HAVE LIKED TO AT
THE BEGINNING. OF ON WERE
CALIFORNIA DAYS WHERE WORKING
WITH PARTNERS LIKE THE LIBRARY.
COMMUNITY FOUNDATIONS
UNDERSTANDING THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY SERVE SO THAT WE CAN
REACH OUT DIRECTLY TO THOSE
MEMBERS THAT ACTUALLY NEED THE
PLATFORM MOST. AND WHAT WAS IS
AYE I DO FIVE. REMEMBER THAT THE
LAUNCH OF ON OR CALIFORNIA BUT
I'M NOT ACTUALLY AS FAMILIAR
WITH- HOW SUCCESSFUL THAT WAS
AND HOW MANY CALIFORNIANS
ACTUALLY UTILIZE THE PROGRAM AND
HOW MANY CALIFORNIANS ACTUALLY.
GOT JOBS AS A RESULT OF THAT
PROGRAM ABSOLUTELY- AND I CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH SOME REAL SOME
REAL DATA POINTS ABOUT I CAN'T
SAY THAT WITHIN. A FEW DAYS OF
LAUNCHING THE PLATFORM OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY CALIFORNIANS WERE
USING THEIR PLATFORM USAGE AND
THEN THE ACTUAL YOU KNOW SUCCESS
RATE I RECOGNIZE THOSE ARE
DIFFERENT AND PART OF WHAT WE
WOULD LOVE TO SEE AND THE NEXT
ROUND OF TOOLS. IS ACTUALLY
DOING MORE OF THAT DIRECT
SUPPORT SERVICE EVEN JUST THAT
YOU KNOW AND COMPANIES LIKE
LINKEDIN CAN'T TRAP OF THE
ACTUAL SUCCESS RATE OF FOLKS
GETTING PLACE TO JOB THAT'S NOT
THE DATA THAT'S COLLECTED. SO
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF INNOVATIVE
WAYS THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED TO
INFUSE IN THE PLOT FORWARD. TO
ACTUALLY TRACK DOWN THOSE
OUTCOMES AND A MORE HOLISTIC WAY
ON IT GAP WELL AND I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH WITH THE POINTS THAT
THAT YOU HAVE MADE- IN TERMS OF
KIND OF A VERY URGENT NEED. TO
UPSKILL AND RESKILL WORKERS IN
OUR INCREASINGLY TECHNOLOGY
DRIVEN ECONOMY THE ONE QUESTION
I DO HAVE IS. THAT IN A WAY IF
WE'RE TRYING TO REACH A GROUP OF
FOLKS THAT. HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO NAVIGATE EXISTING ONLINE
TOOLS IS THE ANSWER ANOTHER
ONLINE TOOL WHERE IS IT IS IT
SOMETHING ALSO HAPPY YOU KNOW
I'LL- SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT
WOULD LOVE TO. THINK JUST
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAYS FOR OUT
REACH TO COMMITTEES THAT HAVE
BEEN AND ARE INCREASINGLY
GETTING LEFT BEHIND INDUCTOR
AMBER IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT
AND YOU'RE CLOSE TO ME MAKE SURE
THERE ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEN
NONE IF YOU WISH TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
ACTUALLY UP LEFT MUCH OF THE
WORK THAT THAT WAS INDUSTRIES
HAS DONE ITSELF IT. DID BEGIN IN
FRESNO BUT NOW IS EXTENDED TO
BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED TO OAKLAND
AND I BELIEVE JUST THIS WEEK
YOU'VE ANNOUNCED EXPANDING INTO
BUFFALO TOLEDO EL PASO. AREAS
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN LEFT
BEHIND MANY TIMES IT'S THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THEMSELVES
WHO. DON'T HAVE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN TACK IT WAS
INDUSTRIES ITSELF WITH JAKE'S
OVERALL AS ITS CO CEO AND- MY
OLD IN JUNIOR WHO I WANT. TO
UPLIFT HERE WHO HAS RE- IN AND-
COMES FROM THE FORMER. COME WHO
KNOWS THE SEE OF THE COMPANY
THAT IS. INVESTING WOMEN. AND
CAN OF. TO BE INVOLVED IN TACK.
WE REALLY ARE DOING SOMETHING
INNOVATIVE HERE I'VE LOVED THE
PARTNERSHIPS. AND ONE UP LIFT
THAT AS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN
DO IT EFFECTIVELY- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY TWO HUNDRED HERE
TODAY SO WE CAN ESTABLISH THIS
GRANT PROGRAM. TO EXPAND AND
SCALE THIS GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU DR RAMBLER POINTS WELL TAKEN
TO GET TO YOUR WITNESSES TODAY
WHO TESTIFIED. I WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
ON AB TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IS DUE
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR. WELL THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY-
COMMITTEE ON LABOR CHAIR
CERVANTES HI. CERVANTES HI VICE
CHAIR CHOI- A VICE CHAIR CHOI I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. THE SELLER
PETRIE-NORRIS II ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH.
SILVERSMITH BY. MEMBERS ON ABOUT
A SIX ZERO AB TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
IS OUT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALL.
AND SECOND ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CHIEF CONSULTOR COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL YES THE TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT OUR ITEM ONE AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
RECOMMEND CONSENT. ITEM TWO AB
TWO TWO TWO SIX THE MAP MOTION
IS DUE PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT RECOMMEND CONSENT
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. SEVEN
MEMBERS MATH HIGH. SIX FEDERAL
RESERVE. OKAY MEMBERS ARE
CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING THANK
YOU.